Alright, so we've got our two attendees. Johnny Concert and Misty Music.
>> Yup.
>> And we've got our two festivals,
ROFLpalooza and Cloudstock. I really like those names.
>>
[LAUGH].
Me too.
>>
>> But can you see the problem here?
>> I mean, they don't have anything to do, like this festival doesn't
know anything about the attendees, so there's no way to like match them.
>> Right. We don't know which festival either of those people are going to.
>> Yeah.
>> So we'll need to relate those two tables.
>> Okay. And so how do we, how do we do that? How do we think about that?
>> So let's take a look at it on the tablet to make it a little more clear.
>> Okay.
>> So, start off by
looking at our festival object. We have the festival here. The, all of
the different field names. And then we
have individual records, like Cloudstock and ROFLpalooza.
>> Right, right. And the fields were our columns. And, I get that.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> So, we could also think about what our attendee object could look like.
>> Here we have same sort of thing. All of our
fields as the columns and then our records as the rows.
>> Okay.
>> But if we were trying to relate these two tables, we would need to create
a relationship field on one of them.
>> Okay. So like, can I think of that as a new column?
>> Think of it as a new column in
the table, exactly. So, what would make more sense, to
add a column onto Attendees relating it to Festival, or
to add a column onto Festival relating it to Attendees?